good morning everyone
for 75 years the NHS has existed for an
enduring moral purpose
to give every single person in our
country the security that comes from
knowing that if you're sick you will be
cared for
rich or Paul
young or old in work or out the NHS is
there for you whenever and wherever you
need it
I believe in the NHS because it's
fundamental to my family my dad was a GP
my mum was a pharmacist
and I saw from an early age the
difference they made to the community
where they lived and worked
and the difference made by the hundreds
of thousands of others who sacrificed so
much for so many in the service of that
higher purpose of protecting our
nation's health
but while that purpose has never changed
what has changed are the challenges
facing the NHS
our society is growing older
the burden of illness is changing and
all of this will put pressure on already
overstretched Workforce
a couple of weeks ago I joined doctors
and nurses on The Late Shift at Watford
General Hospital
I saw courageous hard-working men and
women doing extraordinary things in
difficult circumstances
and they told me the same message we
hear time and time again from leaders in
the healthcare sector and the public
we need more doctors and nurses to ease
the pressures and we need reform to free
them up to do their jobs properly
and they're right
governments from all parties have dug
the challenge for decades
it just isn't right
that we don't train enough people here
at home to properly staff our National
Health Service
now overcoming this won't be quick or
easy
it's only possible because of the
difficult decisions we're taking
elsewhere to cut the debt and by
prioritizing the NHS there will be other
things that we can't afford
but the NHS is too important
so we're making the tough calls and
doing things differently to protect the
long-term future of the NHS and this
country
already we've made progress with more
investment in the NHS than any
government before including up to 14
billion pounds extra for Health and
Social care over the next two years
we've not only hit our Manifesto Target
to recruit 26 000 more Primary Care
staff we've done so one year early
and we're very close to meeting our
promise to recruit fifty thousand more
nurses
and we're cutting the waiting lists with
weights of over two years virtually
eliminated in England and the number of
patients waiting over 18 months reduced
by over 90 percent
but even without the covert backlogs
and even with the record number of
doctors and nurses we have today
unless we act now for the long term the
challenges we Face will only get worse
So today we're announcing the most
ambitious transformation in the way that
we staff the NHS in its history the
long-term Workforce plan
this is a 15-year plan to deliver the
biggest ever expansion in the number of
doctors and nurses that we train
and a plan to reform the NHS so we
deliver better care in a changing world
and a plan that not only eases the
pressures today
but protects this precious National
Institution for the long term
this is the nhs's own plan and the
government is proud to back it
funding the expansion of Education and
Training for the first five years in
full with over 2.4 billion pounds of
additional investment
you can trust this government with the
NHS
the plan rests on three principles train
retain and reform
first training
will double the number of medical
training places by 2031. focusing on
areas where there are too few doctors
today
we'll train over 24
000 more nurses and midwives a year and
increase the number of GP training
places by 50 percent
in time this will allow us to reduce our
spending on temporary agency staff by 10
billion pounds and cut the need for
international recruitment
today the proportion recruited from
overseas is around one in four with our
plan it will fall to just one in ten
second doctors and other clinicians can
spend a lifetime gaining invaluable
experience
we want to hang on to those skills for
as long as we can
so we'll retain more of our dedicated
Workforce keeping up to 130
000 more staff in the NHS over the next
15 years
we already offer best-in-class pensions
and we've just dramatically cut the tax
on pension savings a move that has been
called transformative
now we're going to modernize the pension
scheme so staff can partially retire or
return to work much more easily if they
wish to and we're going to improve
conditions right now
for those who gave so much during the
pandemic to do that we're improving
culture leadership and well-being giving
staff more flexibility and control and
investing in their professional
development
finally we need reform
it's not enough
just to have more doctors and nurses
we need to change the way they work so
that they can deliver better care for
patients
now partly this is about seizing the
opportunities of new technologies like
AI or just look at virtual Wards which
use technology to allow patients to
recover at home providing a better
service at lower cost
but we're also going to expand new roles
like nurse Associates and Physician
Associates so that the most qualified
staff can focus focus on patients with
the most complex needs
we're going to drive the biggest ever
expansion of apprenticeships in the NHS
so that one-fifth of all clinical
training will be offered through degree
apprenticeships helping to bring staff
into the NHS from a much wider range of
backgrounds
and will give staff in the NHS more
opportunities to progress
such as becoming a nurse or a doctor as
well as making sure that the workforce
of the future has the advanced knowledge
they need to care for our aging
population
now taken together these changes will
raise NHS productivity
so patients get more and better care for
the same money
so training retention
and reform that's our plan to build the
healthcare Workforce of the future and
secure the NHS for the long term
next week marks the 75th anniversary of
the NHS
for every minute of every day of every
one of those 75 years
the NHS has been kept going by the
millions of people that have worked for
it
to them on behalf of a Grateful Nation I
want to say thank you
I feel a powerful sense of
responsibility to make sure that their
legacy endures and to make sure that the
NHS is there for our children and
grandchildren
just as it was there for us
and that's what today's plan is all
about
more doctors more nurses
better care for all today and long into
the future
thank you I'm just going to hand over to
Amanda
thank you thank you very much prime
minister
so it's a real pleasure to be with you
here at the launch of the first ever NHS
long-term Workforce plan
as the Prime Minister has just said the
Health Service reaches a major Milestone
next week the 75th anniversary of our
founding
the publication of this ambitious and
bold NHS Clan feels however an even more
significant moment than that anniversary
because it's the first time since 1948
that we have been asked by government to
produce a long-term comprehensive
assessment of our staffing needs and a
plan to deliver them so I would like to
thank the Prime Minister and the
chancellor for wholeheartedly backing
the plan and kick-starting delivery with
significant investment that will fully
fund record numbers of training places
for doctors for nurses and for other
staff needed over the next five years
this is a once in a generation
opportunity to improve Patient Care by
putting Staffing on a sustainable
fitting and I would like just to take
this moment to thank all of my
colleagues across the NHS and Beyond who
have worked so hard with us to produce
it your input has been invaluable
the NHS can do nothing without its staff
the last few years in particular have
shown I think again just the Brilliance
of our staff caring for over a million
people with covid in hospitals
delivering the biggest vaccination
program in our history dealing with the
busiest winter on record as well as
making progress on backlogs and on
cancer diagnoses
however we already have a hundred and
twelve thousand vacancies and as we know
our population is going to grow it's
going to age and as new treatments and
therapies come online the demands on the
NHS and on our own on our Workforce are
only going to increase
since the foundation of the NHS we've
relied on the skills and dedication of
Staff who came here from the four
corners of the globe to care for
patients and there will always be a
place for them in the NHS
demand for healthcare workers is
increasing and will continue increasing
across the world
so doing nothing
is not an option
and as the Prime Minister says we're not
going to do nothing instead we are going
to do the boldest set of changes for
Workforce ever in the history of the NHS
we will increase the number of homegrown
doctors nurses and other staff as part
of the biggest Workforce expansion in
our history and we will draw on the
widest possible pool of talent by
expanding new routes into the profession
so more people can get a nursing or a
medical degree without going to
University full-time
but recruitment is only part of the
answer we will also retain more of the
staff we have and reform the way that
they train and work so we're making the
most of everyone's education skills and
experience
better opportunities for career
development improving flexible working
options alongside government reforms to
the pension scheme should mean around
130 000 more staff stay working in NHS
settings longer
changes in technology and new treatments
will change the way we work in future as
well as the numbers and the roles that
are needed in the future so from care
closer to home with medicines available
on the High Street and more staff
receiving training to spot early signs
of cardiovascular disease cancer and
stroke through to those colleagues
working in Virtual Wards and Beyond this
plan is not just good news for NHS staff
it is good news for patients too
and this plan will be regularly updated
to ensure we stay on track to deliver
the workforce we need to deliver the
best possible care now and into the
future
working in the NHS is not always easy as
the last few years in particular have
shown but it does offer a huge variety
of careers with more than 350 different
roles within the NHS so I would like to
close by urging anyone thinking about
making a change in their career or at
school or university thinking about what
to do next to consider an opportunity
for a career in the NHS
thank you Amanda well brilliant to hear
from the CEO of NHS we're now going to
hear from Steve Powers NHS medical
director Steve over to you thank you
from prime prime minister so as Amanda
has said this is a very important day
indeed and historic day for the NHS for
all who work in it and of course for the
patients that we all care for
I know it takes a team to care for a
patient so not just doctors like me but
nurses physios therapists Porters
cleaners the list goes on
so growing the workforce will help to
ensure that that team have the time they
need to give the standard of care that
they want to provide and that they've
been trained to give
we also have the opportunity to recruit
train and work differently in a way that
is both rewarding for staff and also
more productive for patients and for the
country
so like the Prime Minister and like
Amanda I really truly believe this is a
landmark day for the NHS just ahead of
our 75th anniversary and it's a landmark
day for all who are employed within the
NHS and of course most of all for those
that we care for thank you thank you
Steve
um I'd like to take some questions from
the media can we start with the BBC
please
thank you prime minister hupm BBC News
work on this plan was at least underway
early last year why has it taken so long
to get it launched and have you lost
valuable time there
and a quick second one Lord Goldsmith
has resigned this morning criticizing
you over the environment what's your
reaction and did you ask him to
apologize over his comments on the
Privileges committee
thank you Hugh quick quickly on Lord
Goldsmith he was asked to apologize for
his comments about the Privileges
committee because I felt that those were
incompatible with his position and as a
minister he's obviously chosen to take a
different course uh I accept that I'm
proud of the record of this government
and indeed of Zach in government making
sure that we tackle climate change and
protect our natural environment I think
the UK has played a leadership role
globally and we will continue to do so
uh as as you will see now on on your
question about the plan that you've
you've heard how Amanda and Steve and
numerous other Healthcare bodies have
described it today Landmark historic
momentous important
first time it's happened in 75 years so
it was important that we got it right
because this is a really important day
and this sets the NHS up for decades to
come so taking the time to get it right
is absolutely the correct course of
action and I think as you will be able
to see from the plan today it's very
comprehensive there are three strands to
it it's not just about training more
doctors and nurses of course that's
important and everyone knows we need to
do that and we're doing that but the two
other strands are also important about
how do we retain our fantastic NHS
workers something Amanda might be able
to touch on in a second but you know we
know we need to do a better job of that
and we've got a clear set of initiatives
and proposals that will do that but then
also reform because I know everyone
wants to know that the government is
back in the NHS with funding and we're
doing that record sums that have been
put in by me the chancellor and and
Steve the health secretary but we also
want to make sure that money is well
spent and that the NHS is modernized so
it is fit for the future to deliver the
care that we all need and do so in a way
that is keeping up with how Healthcare
is changing so look three strands train
retain and reform this is a historic
moment it's an important moment this
will set the NHS up for years if not
decades into the future so I don't make
any apology about taking the time to get
it right and I think as you can see from
the reception it's a plan that will be
warmly welcomed and make an enormous
difference to the country and indeed the
NHS and the incredible people that work
for it I don't Amanda you want to touch
on the retention a bit perhaps or what
you know the things that we've been
working on
very happy to talk a bit about retention
because I guess that goes slightly to
your question to you about so you know
the the time that it's going to take
clearly to recruit to train some of the
the staff that we're describing but um I
think the retention actions clearly are
for today they're for now so two really
big things that it's worth mentioning
one is we know flexibility really
matters to our staff so partly that's
been addressed through some of the
pension reforms but we've recently
announced initiatives like enabling
doctors who might be considering
retiring to continue to work more
flexibly for the NHS because we'd rather
have some of their time than none of
their time so a range of things that
will support people particularly with
flexibility around career end the second
thing we know really matters is career
progression so part of this plan of
course is about more of those sorts of
roles that we know can bring people into
the NHS nurse Associates we've talked
about already but also opportunities
then for those people to progress
through so whether that's nurse
Associates becoming qualified nurse is
becoming then Advanced practitioners or
in a range of other ways you know that's
that's the other big component but I
think what Steve would say on retention
and this is another I think important
point about why the long-term
sustainability matters so much is when
you are working in the NHS in fact we
were talking about it as we were coming
over today and you turn up on a shift
and it's you know people you're not
familiar with working where there are
gaps in the rotors you know that makes
it really hard for people to feel they
can do their best work looking after
patients so knowing that own time we
will get to a place where we have a
sustainable Workforce Solution also
matters for staff who are working with
us today I think just quickly before we
move on about the time that we've been
spending to get this right and Steve
maybe could spend 30 seconds on it is we
also wanted to engage and listen to
people right this wasn't a plan that you
know Amanda and Steve just concocted in
their office and then sat down with
Steve and me and the chancellor to put
together this what we've been doing with
the time is talking to I think something
like 60 odd organizations and 100
experts in the healthcare field and
Steve can speak to that because he's
been doing a lot of that engagement and
we chaired a round table just here in
Downing Street earlier this week because
we wanted to make sure that we heard
from everyone involved in the NHS and
that we got all their ideas on board we
discussed with them what they were
looking for what what were the things
that would make the most difference and
make sure that we do this together
because ultimately I can stand here and
announce this you know Amanda and Steve
are here with me and as we've discussed
with everyone else earlier this week
this is a plan that will ultimately need
to be delivered by all the incredible
people working and leading the NHS so
it's important that they were part of
this journey and that the plan is as
much theirs as it is ours but see I mean
you've been doing that for months so
that's an incredibly important point
because part of the reason it's taken
time is because we really wanted to
engage with all the people that we've
worked for so Jeanette is sitting in the
audience today the upcoming chairman of
the Academy of Medical Royal colleges
and the medical Royal colleges and the
medical space have been working closely
with us but also professional bodies
throughout all the professions in the
NHS what struck me at the round table
that was held here earlier this week was
just the positivity from all those
representatives of all those key bodies
that were were in the room they were up
for the challenge they recognized that
this is rightly a challenging plan uh
both in terms of numbers uh and both in
terms of the reform that needs to happen
but they weren't for it I've been
talking to leaders of universities the
university leaders who were in the room
as well earlier this week to the GMC
who's a regulator on the medical
Workforce on on the ambition to shorten
the curriculum for medical students to
introduce apprenticeships to widen the
access for people coming into medical
schools they are really up for it yes
it's going to be challenging over the
five-year period where where the 2.4
billion is targeted that is around the
time scale it will take to build the new
medical schools to put the additional
places uh in in the system but uh it's a
challenge but people people are
absolutely up for it and it is entirely
doable
thank you right return to ITV next
just on ITV News there's lots of new
money in here prime minister for
training but not new money for pay and
yet we've had former NHS workers tell us
that one of the reasons they left was
below inflation pay Rises I just wanted
to ask you do you accept that pay hits
morale in the NHS and also this is in
the long term what will it mean for
patients who are on waiting lists now
and to Amanda Pritchard and to Steve
powers can I just ask you about
short-term Workforce challenge you're
facing how worried are you about doctor
strikes next month and do you want to
see the government do more to stop them
look of course would everyone like to be
paid more of course they would be but I
think everyone also recognizes the
economic context that we're in and our
job in government is to balance all
those things make sure that we reward
people fairly and well for the
incredible work they're doing
particularly our NHS workers but also
make sure that we're doing things that
are good for them and the rest of the
country in the long term and that means
bringing down inflation because it won't
help anybody if we just take the easy
course and ultimately make the situation
worse and last longer and actually I'm
really pleased that the NHS staff
Council which represents it over half a
dozen unions over a million NHS workers
actually voted to accept the
government's pay offer because when they
did recognize that it was fair and
reasonable rewarded their members for
the hard work and I'm very grateful to
all of them for doing that because I
know that fundamentally what they care
about is working really hard to deliver
excellent health care we wanted to
reward that the five percent pay rise
for this forthcoming year together with
one-off bonuses of up to two thousand
pounds that money is going to be hitting
people's pay packets literally in the
next months it will start making a real
difference to people but it is important
that we balance all these considerations
and we'll continue to do so but also
it's the reason we can do this today
is because we in government prioritize
we prioritize the things that are really
important no government can do
absolutely everything of course they
can't and particularly not in the
economic circumstances that we face now
that we enormously counterproductive but
this is something that you know the
chancellor and I have known that we
wanted to do for a long time in fact
Jeremy wrote a book about this some
years ago and so we've always known we
wanted to do this and we've made sure
that in all our thinking and all our
financial planning that we would be able
to fund this because we knew that this
was the right thing to do and it was the
country's number one priority it was our
priority to put the NHS on a secure
footing for the long term to do the
difficult thing that no other government
has done before that's what we've done
today but that does involve looking in
the round and prioritizing and that's
what we've done and I think I mean you
should talk to Amanda and Steve but you
talked about Amanda's already talked
about retention look there are many
reasons that go into how can we improve
retention in the NHS I won't repeat
everything Amanda says but we are
investing in lots of them I mean I think
actually I was just talking to people
this morning when I was out in Cambridge
at the hospital but all there something
that's valuable to them is the training
support they get after they start work
and that's something that we've done
right we've introduced a 1 000 pound
training budget for nurses midwives once
they qualify they get access to a
training budget to continue to support
continue supporting them in their career
so there are other ways that we can
support people alongside pay
um but and on the on the workforce
challenges of today obviously you should
hear from Amanda and Steve but of course
it is challenging when people take
industrial action we've already had over
half a million patients care disrupted
as a result of industrial action I don't
want to see that I'm sure Amanda and
Steve don't want to see that so you know
I'd ask everyone to recognize the
economic context that we're in and as I
said I'm very grateful to the NHS staff
Council and the over a million workers
they represent for accepting the
government's paid deal and working with
us to deliver great quality Care
I don't think you want to add Amanda
probably not not a great deal but I
think it is worth just really taking a
moment to acknowledge your level of
pressure that our colleagues in the NHS
are under
enormous demands both from kind of
covered backlogs as well as as well as
everyday pressures so I think that is
why it is so important that we do have a
long-term plan that gives a clear kind
of blueprint to get to a place where we
will have a more sustainable to
sustainable Staffing position within the
NHS because we know how much that
matters to staff now as well as how much
that matters for us being able to
provide the care that we need to provide
for patients in the future as well short
term and we've talked a lot about the
retention aspect of the plan already
there's a lot more detail behind it that
we could certainly talk about but I
think we're very conscious that it is
really important that you know my only
job it's it's not my job to deal with
the issues of pay that's between
government and the unions but it is my
job to make sure that we are doing
everything we can to support patients to
support our staff to be able to work in
a way that feels well supported whether
they've got this flexibility that works
for them and works for patients but
they've got the career development that
we know matters for them and that's why
that's such a big part of the plan
simply on planning for strikes and I'm
aware that there are more strikes
planned for for next month uh we will be
doing what we've been doing throughout
our job Amanda and our colleagues in NHS
our job is to prepare for those strikes
to ensure that we keep patients safe
that we keep those Services going that
we can keep going of course we'll be
focusing on making sure Emergency
Services maternity Services trauma
service those key Services uh are kept
uh intact and running as normal and a
safe and safe we will be of course
keeping channels open with the unions to
flag to them anything that we are
worried about and we expect them to
respond positively uh if we do that so
we will be doing that of course uh we
want to support our staff whether
they're striking or not and of course
all of us would like to see these
disputes resolved and as the Prime
Minister said some of those disputes
have been resolved over the course of
the year and even for senior doctors if
you go back to early this year when the
BMA set out what they wanted to see one
of the three things was on pensions
reform and of course pensions reform has
been delivered and that now is off the
table as an issue so you know I have to
remain I always will remain optimistic
that we can make progress but what we're
talking about today is is both in the
short term and and in the long term
putting in place the conditions that
mean job satisfaction uh and getting
people uh enjoying work and wanting to
come uh to work uh is is there uh every
day uh every week in the NHS and putting
in more resilience because it has been a
really tough time as Amanda has said
particularly over the pandemic I just
add I mean I I sit down with Steve
Amanda and Steve and others almost every
week and in spite of the industrial
action we are still making progress on
cutting the waiting list right and as
that you know down to the extraordinary
efforts of everyone involved but if you
look at waiting lists we've as I said
virtually eliminated uh one and a half
year waiters eliminated two-year waiters
last year look at a e and ambulance
times strong recovery from Winter we're
rolling out virtual War Baltimore
Hospital surgical hubs to do elective
surgery more Community diagnostic
Centers more use of virtual wards that
all those things are making a difference
right now and improving people's
experience with NHS improving their care
and we're managing to do that in spite
of the industrial action and that's
thanks to an enormous amount of hard
work from a lot of people and that is
when I said we put record funding in
weeks after I became prime minister
we're using that funding to good effect
uh next GB news
from Foster GB news obviously a huge
amount to be welcomed in these plans
but in the short term you've got cut
waiting list and blazing across all the
podiums
currently we've got record 7.4 million
people on waiting lists we've got Junior
doctors going to strike for five days
also Consultants
you spent last year saying we'll go with
whatever the independent pay review body
recommends now you're not guaranteeing
that you'll do even that
are you confident that you can deliver
on this priority and all of your five
priorities in a significant way before
the next election
the simple answer is yes I am and that's
why I set them out very clearly at the
beginning of the year actually unusual
and it's great that everyone's talking
about them because I think it's right
that leaders and politicians set very
clear objectives make it crystal clear
to the country what they're trying to
achieve so that I and everyone else can
be held accountable for them and it's
good that they're transparent and
everyone can understand what we're about
and we are making progress in spite of
the challenges that we Face we are doing
things that are improving people's
experience of patient care right now as
I said for their sins Amanda and Steve
have to come and see me all the time and
we go through this on a very regular
basis together with Steve but let's just
talk let's talk about urgent and
Emergency Care everyone remembers how
challenging that was over the winter you
know we have an urgent Emergency Care
recovery plan it involves more doctors
more nurses more ambulances then also
more use of faster discharge and virtual
Awards look all of those things are
helping us improve our
urgent and Emergency Care performance
ambulance waiting times that were one
and a half hours cat two overwintered
down to around about half an hour and
we're making good progress a e waiting
times around you know they were 65 four
hours uh at the worst point now close to
75 you know virtual Ward Steve is doing
a good job of rolling out across the
country what does that mean stops people
from coming into Hospital in the first
place gets them home quicker once
they're there better patient care for
them improves the flow through the
hospital the money that we've put into
social care helping us discharge people
quicker out of hospitals because they
should be at home and need to be at home
that also helps so I the money that
we've put in the chancellor put in as I
said weeks after I took office is making
a real difference is making a real
difference right now to people and is
industrial action challenging of course
it's challenging to make everything
harder of course it does but we are
still making progress and in terms of
the backlogs we always knew that they
would continue to grow right there's the
bounce back from covert that we knew
would happen that was always forecast to
happen but in spite of that we're
eliminating steadily but surely the
people who are waiting a very long time
just recently we made a significant
announcement to give people choice about
where they get their treatment so from
now on when you get referred for further
treatment from your GP you'll be able to
use the website or your app to select
from different providers and in doing so
you'll be able to cut your waiting times
because we know and the research is very
clear that actually once you give that
choice to people and they have the
option of choosing a different hospital
it can cut waiting times by around three
months and that's something that we are
now in the process of rolling out and
later this year that choice will be
extended to people who are already on
waiting lists and that will help us
bring the waiting list down even further
so those are all examples of things
we're doing right now that will make a
big difference to people and that's why
I'm confident we will continue to make
progress and people will continue to see
their Improvement of the NHS at all
levels
urgent and Emergency Care elective and
outpatient Primary Care will just
continue to improve that's what we're
all dedicated to deliver and I'm
confident that we will
uh Telegraph
many people find it very hard to get an
NHS dentist
do you think that um the more dentists
should work in the NHS and is there
anything in the plan which would help
achieve that uh the simple answer is yes
and yes so we you know the plan has an
increase in dentistry training places
that you might want to talk about in a
little bit more detail perhaps um but
that's in the plan as well and that we
are aware of the challenges in NHS
Dentistry uh We've obviously reformed
the Dentistry contracts that's something
we've done recently we're allowing some
dentists that are high performing to do
up to 10 more than their contracted
amounts there are more dentists in the
NHS today hundreds than there were
previously and we're seeing far more
children now through NHS Dentistry than
we were a year before but I know that
there are challenges the long-term
Workforce plan will help us fix those
over time and the other thing that we
are exploring is the the possibility of
introducing a what's called a tie-in for
Dentistry around about two-thirds of uh
dentists after they finish their
specialty training end up not uh doing
work in the NHS and that's something
that we want to look at and it may be
that the appropriate thing to do is to
introduce a tie so that people are
performing more NHS work after they
qualify of course they've benefited from
a very significant subsidy from the
taxpayer worth hundreds of thousands of
pounds so that seems a reasonable
approach that's something we're going to
explore but we are also a funding and
expansion of Dental training places I
don't know city of Roman or anything you
want to add on that well it's exactly
that we are in the plan there is a plan
to expand Dental training places as well
and also Allied professions to Dentistry
as well so that will put more capacity
in more dentists uh into the system over
time as well uh the tie-in Prime
Minister talked about that's something
that we're considering as well but of
course there are wider issues around
access to dentistry and so we are
working collectively with
secretary-state and others around dental
recovery plan as well so um I guess most
of them on that I yeah I think like we
talk about this reform piece and we
haven't talked about it very much
actually in the Q a but one of the
examples of Reform is in dentistry where
we can have people who are not dentists
but are in as a Allied health
professionals where it's um I think what
they call it a therapist or dental one
of the roles whether we expect them to
do more dental work going forward than
they've done in the past and that's one
of the regulatory changes that we're
looking at making again that's an
example of us doing things differently
modernizing the Health Service but we
want everyone to be operating at the top
of their license right so the people who
are got the full brand spanking degree
should focus on the things that only
they can do and where we can find
different roles to create new roles
change how we regulate to allow other
people to perform other tasks that they
are capable of doing that's what we
should be doing that will improve
healthcare for all of us and make a more
productive Healthcare System and
actually we're doing that in dentistry
as well as doing it everywhere else
okay next Daily Mail
thanks Liam um one for the Medics you've
got
um patient satisfaction at her record
low this is obviously a long-term plan
realistically will people start to
notice any difference within the next 12
months
or given that you've got strikes going
on I thought and Center like people have
to accept that things will get worse
before they get better and PM can I ask
you about yesterday's appeal court
judgment
um are you confident that you can win in
the Supreme Court you're surprised to
find the uh unhcr arguing against you
when it sends people there itself and
will we finally get the first flight in
the air this year
did you guys want to take the first one
and then oh yeah
yeah kick off on that one so thank you
so I think your question about will will
patients notice a difference well so
everything we are doing is of course
geared towards making things better for
patients as well as making sure that our
staff have really rewarding careers and
they have enough people with the right
skills to enable them to look after the
patients the way we know they want to so
the things that will make a difference
immediately we've talked about some of
the really important things on retention
some of the new roles that we've talked
about uh prime minister just mentioned
reform some of the new roles and the
increases in those roles will come on
stream much more quickly because the
training periods are obviously are
reduced and so I think there is a lot in
this plan that speaks to today as well
as the confidence it can give our
current staff about the fact that we
will get to a place where we have a
sustainable Staffing model in the longer
term on the range of things though
outside just the workforce plan I think
the Prime Minister has actually just
given a pretty comprehensive run through
of many of the things that we are doing
which are all about making sure that we
are making an impact as we already are
whether that is on reducing the number
of people who are waiting as we say
virtually eliminated now two-year
weights over 90 reduction in 18. month
Waits and we're now focused on 65 weeks
is the next uh big Target on that or
it's about the work that we're doing to
improve ambulance response times a e
performance both of which have
sustainably and significantly improved
since winter or it's the work we're
doing on increasing the number of people
getting cancer checks record levels
which is leading to record numbers of
people being diagnosed at stage one and
stage two and actually we're seeing that
impact now on survival rates which is
ultimately you know the the Big Goal
there so whether you're looking at any
of those things or indeed Primary Care
where we've recently launched a primary
care access recovery plan which has a
range of things in that to support
incredibly hard-working colleagues in
Primary Care through things and
secretary of state has been working very
closely with us on all of this looking
at where we can use things like
technology to really make things better
not just for patients easier for them
but better and easier for our staff too
so I would I would very much hope that
patients will already see the benefit of
the work that we've been doing on those
sorts of things but certainly a lot more
to come can I just emphasize something
sorry before Steve comes in that Amanda
said I think is really important and
probably not well understood right now
the NHS is doing more
treating more people seeing more people
diagnosing more people scanning more
people than it has ever done right so
because of the investment that we've put
in and because of the Innovations in how
we're doing things or the whether it's
virtual Awards or Community diagnostic
Centers or elective surgical hubs
whatever it might be all the new ways
we're doing things and the funding the
NHS is doing more than it's ever done
right so yes do we of course we have a
challenge that people are waiting longer
than we'd like yes we know why that is
it's because we have a massive backlog
that built up over two years of covert
where we were not able to see everyone
and we always knew that would be the
case but people should be reassured that
because of the investment and the hard
work and the Innovations right now
thousands and thousands of people every
day are being seen who would not have
otherwise been seen and that's because
of the extra as I said funding resources
innovations that we're we're putting in
so yes we will get that's why I'm
confident we will get there and the
trajectory for all those things is up
right we have plans for all of these
things to just keep increasing the
amount of activity that the NHS can do
and that's how we will ultimately bring
all these waiting lists down Steve you
don't think you want that well you
mentioned surveys and and when we look
at surveys and what we when we hear what
people tell us what they tell us is that
they very firmly believe in the
principles of the NHS and the NHS as it
uh as it is set up as a delivery model
for for healthcare uh they tell us that
when they get care they're very
satisfied but what they're frustrated at
is access to care whether it's in
general practice you mentioned dentistry
and of course getting people to Urgent
emergency care services quickly as well
and that's why that has been the focus
of the plans that we have published with
the government uh this year and a very
very specific example that Amanda
touched on which is in general practice
well we know again that the levels of
satisfaction are high when you see
somebody in primary care when you see a
healthcare professional GPU or other
other clinician but there's a
frustration in getting through that 8
A.M you know a log Jam on a Monday
morning uh Cloud telephony which sounds
a really simple thing uh you know
technology that is used in other
Industries people will be familiar with
but it's actually transformational and
if you go and stand for a morning or
visit for a morning a surgery where they
have implemented it what you see is
behind the scenes of practice that is
that is getting access to people on the
day that is sorting the problems uh who
are who are able to call back
automatically rather than people hanging
on who are able to know how many people
are waiting and therefore divert staff
in order to deal with the pressures at a
particular time of day who have got
their processes sorted behind the scenes
to ensure that the patient gets to the
right clinician that might be a phone
call it might be a digital consultation
it might be a face-to-face appointment
at a time that the patient is convenient
to the patients and and that is the
future of primary care and when you see
it in action it is really really quite
quite transformational and Incredibly
impressive So the plan is to use
technology and to use this Workforce
plan and the other plans that we've got
to make sure that happens everywhere not
just somewhere and that's exactly what
we aim to do and just on on Steve's
point on primary care which is the
exactly right and very well made what
are we doing we're providing grants for
thousands of GP practices so that they
can switch to the system that Steve just
described that is so much better for
patients so we are saying to GP
practices sign up we're going to give
you a grant so that you can install that
cloud-based telephony system get the
training by the way that you also need
for your teams and support you while you
do the transition there's now a grant
available from us we funded that because
we think that will make a big difference
to people's experience of accessing
their GP by moving to that new
technology and what are one of the other
things we're doing we're changing how
pharmacies work moving to a pharmacy
first model where this winter you will
be able to go to your pharmacist and for
seven common ailments like ear
infections sore throats sinusitis UTIs
and other things the pharmacist will be
able to give you the medicines that you
need right that is an example of us
doing something differently as well as
expanding more blood pressure checks and
indeed oral contraception in pharmacies
that again means that people will be
able to get access to health care
quicker leave some of pressure on GPS
and to Amanda's Point these are the
types of examples of things that are
making a difference in the here and now
and on your other question Jason look I
I respect the court but I fundamentally
disagree with their conclusions you know
I strongly believe and the law chief
justice made clear that he agrees with
this as well that the rwandans have
provided all the assurances necessary to
ensure that there is no real risk that
Asylum Seekers that are relocated under
our policy would be wrongly returned to
third countries Rwanda is a safe country
the high court agrees with that and
indeed you mentioned the unhcr they use
Rwanda for their own Refugee scheme for
Libyan refugees and given all of that
we're going to seek permission to appeal
this decision to the Supreme Court and
I'll said it before from here I'll say
again the policy of this government is
very simple it is your government and it
is not criminal gangs who should decide
who comes here right it is a very simple
point of view it is out country is our
government who should decide who comes
here not criminal gangs and I'll do what
is necessary to make sure that that
happens
I said that well there's a matter for
the courts in terms of their timeline
um next week I know we're running out of
time so let's try and rather a couple
more of the Sun
and we know that thousands of doctors
are fleeing to Australia to go and take
advantage of their really lucrative
system and really good pay and offers
the conditions that they've got over
there
um obviously after training in the NHS
for many many years
um obviously at the taxpayers expense do
you not guys not think that there should
be some form of mandatory training to
keep those doctors in the NHS for longer
and just on Rwanda if I may what is your
plan B for those Victoria MPS who are
saying this plan just might not work it
might not take off the ground and how
are those talks going with other
countries to put in similar deals if
this plan doesn't come through thank you
um I'll do quickly both of those look on
your first point look I read all those
reports as well and I was concerned
Health secretary was concerned uh we sat
down and we went through it all together
actually we just went and looked through
the data and the data shows that that it
is not as widespread a practice as I
think people assume it is and clearly if
it was we would look to do something and
that's why with Dentistry as we've
touched on before where we think there
is a potential issue there we are
exploring as you mentioned the
possibility of introducing a dental
tie-in but when it comes to doctors and
Steve might have better numbers than me
but it was around I think a 95 of people
who after they've completed their
foundation training were still working
in the NHS so I think the scale of what
is happening is not at the level that
people commonly assume it is and for
that reason we didn't think it was the
right approach but I said if we think
there is an issue we are prepared to
take action and you're seeing that uh
with Dentistry where we're contemplating
whether it doesn't make sense to
introduce the tie and on uh on Rwanda
you know I'll just repeat what I said
before like we are confident in our case
right the high court agreed with us the
law chief justice agreed with us you
know Rwanda Rwanda doesn't even have
returns agreements with other countries
and they've provided a set of safeguards
and assurances to us about the treatment
of refugees that will be sent there that
we believe are strong as I said the high
court and the law chief justice agreed
with that so we will seek permission to
appeal this case to the Supreme Court
and will remain entirely confident that
what we're doing is right and it is also
Fair
because there is nothing moral or
compassionate by allowing the current
system to continue right people are just
needlessly dying as they try and make
these crossings they are exploited by
criminal gangs you spend any time with
the people who are actually as I've done
in the channel picking people up seeing
the conditions that they are subject to
seeing what children are subject to
would find it very hard to justify
maintaining the system and this will
always be a compassionate and honoring
country we have welcomed almost half a
million people here from all different
parts of the world over the last few
years we will continue to do that but we
want to make sure that that compassion
is targeted on the people who most need
our help and that our generosity is not
exploited by gangs and that is what our
policy will seek to do and you talk
about other deals you know we you can
already see some signs of progress there
with the cooperation that we're having
with the French but also Albania where
our new returns agreement and the new
approach to dealing with illegal
migrants from Albania means that we have
reduced the numbers by around 90 percent
so far since that deal was signed and
we've returned almost 2 000 illegal
migrants to Albania so that to me shows
that deterrence works so when you can
have a system where people know that if
they come here illegally they won't be
allowed to stay they will be returned
they stop coming and that's the policy
that we want to roll out more broadly
um great last one from the times
and the times I just want a quick point
of clarification first about the
breakdown this uh 2.4 billion how much
of that is year one year two year three
point five so you can just see how that
splits out and then on productivity
um Amanda Pritchard and Professor Powers
you're both pretty clear in this plan
you think the productivity Targets in
here can only be hit if there is more
money available for buildings and
Technology have you put a figure on that
and are you saying that these targets
can't be hit unless there is more
investment in those areas and prime
minister I mean you point out rightly
that you know the answer has more staff
more money than before yet productivity
has fallen why do you think that is and
do you agree with those who say it can't
that can't be worse unless we spend more
than we do now on birds building and
Technology
no so you know why is productivity
Fallen well you know we had a two-year
pandemic Chris that impacted the NHS
quite considerably and impacted how it
had to work within in uh infection
prevention controls lots of other
measures that had to be introduced so
look of course productivity took a hit
whilst that was going on but what I'm
confident about now is that productivity
will increase it will increase because
not just that we're putting in more
funding record funding in fact but we're
doing things differently right we talked
about virtual Awards we've talked about
surgical hubs we talked about Community
diagnostic Centers all of those are
examples of how we can do more with the
resources that we have by being clever
by thinking innovatively by learning
from best practice elsewhere and rolling
that out across the system and Steve
could talk to in detail about any one of
those things but elective surgical hubs
which mean that we protect outpatient or
surgical capacity away from the acute
centers that's good for productivity
Community diagnostic Centers just
improve our ability to maintain
Diagnostics particularly for cancer as
Amanda mentioned that's improving our
productivity where we're using AI as
well talk to you know Radiologists and
radiographers now particularly in
dermatology how they're using AI to save
them time diagnose things spot things uh
and and mean that they can spend more
time doing more things that's increasing
productivity as we speak and then all
the measures about reform in this plan
the new roles that we're creating nurse
Associates Physician Associates
Anesthesia Associates those are the
types of examples of things that will
improve productivity which is why I
think we're confident that we can grow
it over time and it's right that we do
because I want to make sure the NHS is
fully funded I believe in the NHS that's
why the government's put record funding
in but I also think it's right that for
taxpayers we perform as productively as
we can and I think that's what people
want to see right everyone is happy to
fund the NHS but they want to make sure
that it is delivering at the best of its
capability and that was something that
was very important to me as we the plan
was put together and it is the most
ambitious set of reforms I think
probably in the NHS history when it
comes to how we recruit train people and
how they work and that's what gives all
of us confidence that we can drive our
productivity over time and quickly on
Capital there's record sums of capital
going into the NHS you can see that for
example in CDC as being a good example
where we're well on our way to getting
180 or 90 order those I think done
and Hospital upgrades everywhere and as
you know the new hospital program so
look there's record sums of capital
going in and there will continue to be
strong financial support for the NHS
thank you and so I think it's probably
worth saying everything that this plan
is about as I've said before is about
making sure that we have the workforce
that we need for the long term to
deliver for our patients and we
absolutely recognize the level of
pressure on our staff at the moment but
also just the challenge that the
pandemic has left us with and some of
the things that were pre-pandemic as
well so you know this is not a kind of
overnight magic one solution what this
is is a set of things that are going to
make a difference now in the medium term
and in the long term to get us to that
position and to continue to make
progress but on your point about
productivity I think again just really
important to say this is not about
people working harder and I think that's
absolutely critical this is about people
working differently so three things
prime minister's already called them out
this is going to be absolutely
recognizing the way that we're changing
the way we provide services so more in
the community more done with remotely
the ability to shift care out of
hospitals great if you need to be in
hospital but if you don't we can do it
better by helping people to get the care
they need out of hospital that's what we
want to do and that's written through
the plan secondly it's about new roles
and again we've talked about some of
those already but that's part of
creating the right mix of skills for
teams so that they can deliver for
patients as effectively as possible and
but it is also going to be about
continuing to see investment as we have
in digital in technology and of course
in the physical estate as well
Steve anything on your own yeah only to
Echo that I think there is a great
opportunity in the technology that we
are seeing now artificial intelligence
robotics uh to drive productivity we've
seen productivity gained in the past by
things such as reducing length of stay
and that of course has been harder over
the period of the pandemic but robotics
for instance allow patients to go home
earlier uh post-operation so Radiology
um you know Jeanette I mentioned already
you see it from the academy was previous
president of the Royal College of
Radiologists and we're working very
closely with the Radiologists and
Radiologists on Imaging and how
artificial intelligence can be used in
imaging for instance in Strokes if you
have a potential acute stroke the
diagnosis now is aided through
artificial intelligence uh also helping
the Radiologists in terms of Imaging so
I think you will see much much more of
this going forward and there's a real
opportunity in clinical areas also in
non-clinical areas as well just
Administration and automated processes
to drive those productivity gains so yes
it is an important thing perfect
um just in conclusion I always just say
this is an incredibly important day for
the NHS and for the country and you know
all of you have seen the comments from
different stakeholders and it's rare
that people use words like historic and
momentous uh to describe something that
government and organizations do but I
think those are the right words to use
to describe what's happening today
because for 75 years the NHS has not had
a long-term Workforce plan and for the
first time it will and it's right
everyone takes a moment to recognize the
significance of that moment and I want
to put on record my thanks particularly
to the chancellor in the health
secretary but Stephen Amanda and all the
many many people who have helped feed in
to this plan because that's what it
takes for us to deliver this I said that
earlier on but I really meant it like
there are over a million people that
work in the NHS but all the people are
involved in implementing this plan and
now have a responsibility and a joint
Collective effort with all of us to
deliver the incred edible things that
this plan is capable of doing and if we
can do that then we can do something
incredibly special for the country and
for all the incredible people in the NHS
and deliver a healthcare system that is
completely fit for the future for years
if not decades to come providing a
modernized Health Service that is
effective that gets people the care they
need when they need it in the way that
they need it and I said it's an example
of this government doing difficult
long-term things that are the right
thing for the country it's probably one
of the most significant things I'll do
as prime minister it's a real personal
moment apply for me to be able to
support this plan because as I said I
think it's what the country in the NHS
needs and I'm glad that we can do it
thank you very much